Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Approximately 5 months ago, we talked about
a technique called Neural Radiance Fields,
or NERF in short, that worked on a 5D neural
radiance field representation.
So what does this mean exactly?
What this means is that we have 3 dimensions
for location and two for view direction, or
in short, the input is where we are in space
give it to a neural network to learn it, and
synthesize new, previously unseen views of
not just the materials in the scene, but the
entire scene itself.
In short, it can learn and reproduce entire
real-world scenes from only a few views by
using neural networks.
And the results were just out of this world.
Look.
It could deal with many kinds of matte and
glossy materials, and even refractions worked
quite well.
It also understood depth so accurately that
we could use it for augmented reality applications
where we put a new, virtual object in the
scene and it correctly determined whether
it is in front of, or behind the real objects
in the scene.
However, not everything was perfect.
In many cases, it had trouble with scenes
with variable lighting conditions and lots
of occluders.
You might ask, is that a problem?
Well, imagine a use case of a tourist attraction
that a lot of people take photos of, and we
then have a collection of photos taken during
a different time of the day, and of course,
with a lot of people around.
But, hey, remember that this means an application
where we have exactly these conditions: a
wide variety of illumination changes and occluders.
This is exactly what NERF was not too good
at!
Let’s see how it did on such a case.
Yes, we see both abrupt changes in the illumination,
and the remnants of the folks occluding the
Brandenburg Gate as well.
And this is where this new technique from
scientists at Google Research by the name
NERF-W shines.
It takes such a photo collection, and tries
to reconstruct the whole scene from it, which
we can, again, render from new viewpoints.
So, how well did the new method do in this
case?
Let’s see.
Wow.
Just look at how consistent those results
are.
So much improvement in just 6 months of time.
This is unbelievable.
This is how it did in a similar case with
the Trevi fountain.
Absolutely beautiful.
And what is even more beautiful is that since
it has variation in the viewpoint information,
we can change these viewpoints around as the
algorithm learned to reconstruct the scene
itself.
This is something that the original NERF technique
could also do, however, what it couldn’t
do, is the same, with illumination.
Now, we can also change the lighting conditions
together with the viewpoint.
This truly showcases a deep understanding
of illumination and geometry.
That is not trivial at all!
For instance, when loading this scene into
this neural re-rendering technique from last
year, it couldn’t tell whether we see just
color variations on the same geometry, or
if the geometry itself is changing.
And, look, this new method does much better
on cases like this.
So clean!
Now that we have seen the images, let’s
see what the numbers say for these scenes.
The NRW is the neural re-rendering technique
we just saw, and the other one is the NERF
paper from this year.
The abbreviations show different ways of comparing
the output images, the up and down arrows
show whether they are subject to maximization
or minimization.
They are both relatively close, but, when
we look at the new method, we see one of the
rare cases where it wins decisively regardless
of what we are measuring.
Incredible.
This paper truly is a great leap in just a
few months, but of course, not everything
is perfect here.
This technique may fail to reconstruct regions
that are only visible on just a few photos
in the input dataset.
The training still takes from hours to days,
I take this as an interesting detail more
than a limitation since this training only
has to be done once, and then, using the technique
can take place very quickly.
But, with that, there you go, a neural algorithm
that understands lighting, geometry, can disentangle
the two, and reconstruct real-world scenes
from just a few photos.
It truly feels like we are living in a science
fiction world.
What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!